One of my pet peeves is sometimes
unintentional gatekeeping that happens in the DEI space.
And so that's why I wanted to come back
and answer this question thoroughly.
DEI stands for diversity,
equity, and inclusion.
It's about truly
valuing and appreciating the diversity in people.
It is about acknowledge
acknowledging the systemic inequities in society
and about including those who have been marginalized.
It's also really important to acknowledge the history.
Back when I started this work almost 20,
maybe more than 20 years ago,
it was referred to as DNI.
It was diversity and inclusion.
And even before that, in the 60,
70s and 80s,
it was more focused on the diversity aspect,
which was a response to the civil rights movement.
Such an important point to emphasize
because this is a movement
that was started by and for black people.
And in the heart of becoming more inclusive,
of course, all sorts of other
under represented
marginalized identities
have been included in this space,
like women, like people with disabilities, LGBTQ,
to plus community,
and of course,
indigenous people and other people of color.
So as other groups become included,
and it helps make this work even more relatable,
that's a good, good thing.
But also what can unintentionally happen
is whiteness gets centered in the work,
and the most marginalized are de centered,
which is the opposite intention of diversity,
equity and inclusion.
It's why I identify as an intersectional feminist,
because I need to be
Aware of the most marginalized women
in terms of their intersectionality,
the multiple identities that they can hold
at the same time,
and still acknowledging how gender shows up
in our power structures.
So when talking about power structures,
it's important to recognize
that in that power structure,
whiteness is at the top.
And so good example of this
is how white women have been shown
in the US election
to vote against their own self interest as a woman,
and give up their rights as a woman,
to prioritize their identity
as a white person.
And so, returning to my original point
around gatekeeping,
this is why,
unintentionally,
we do this by adding all of these acronyms.
But it's really just
because there are different areas of focus
that need to be highlighted at times.
And so here is a list of all the ways that you might
see this work framed.
And if you have any other questions,
let me know in the comments.